Hello Greek
bitches.
Do you think in our lifetimes and or in
our children's lifetime,
it's feasible that we figure out a way
in some way to,
I'm not endorsing like taking people's
money and giving it to other people,
but in some sort of a way to eliminate
poverty.
Is that even possible?
Is it ever going to be possible to
completely eliminate poverty worldwide
and within like a lifetime?
Well,
I think we talked about this the last
time when we spoke about ai,
but I mean this is the implication of
much of what we talked about here.
If you,
if you imagine building the perfect
labor saving technology,
right?
What do you imagine?
Imagine just having a machine that can
build any machine that can do any human
labor.
You powered by sunlight more or less for
the cost of raw materials,
right?
So you're talking about the ultimate
wealth generation device and now we're
not just talking about blue collar
labor,
we're talking about the kind of labor
you and I do,
right?
So like artistic labor and scientific
labor and,
um,
you know,
just a machine that comes up with good
ideas.
Right?
And He,
what we're talking about,
general artificial intelligence,
um,
this if in the right political and
economic system,
this would just cancel any need for
people to have to work to survive,
right?
It just would be,
there'd be enough of everything to go
around.
And then the question would be,
do we have the right political and
economic system where we,
where we actually could spread that
wealth or would we just,
we just find ourselves in some kind of
horrendous arms race and,
and,
uh,
situation of,
of wealth inequality,
uh,
unlike any we've ever seen.
Um,
it's a,
um,
we don't,
we don't have the,
it's not in place now and if someone
just handed us this device,
you know,
if,
um,
and it were,
you know,
all of my concerns about Ai,
we're gone.
I mean,
there's no question about this thing,
uh,
doing things we didn't want it would do
exactly what we want when we want it.
And there's no,
there's just no danger of it.
Uh,
it's interest becoming misaligned with
our own.
It's just like a perfect oracle and a
perfect designer of new technology.
Um,
if,
if it was handed to us now,
you know,
I would expect just complete chaos,
right?
I would explain it if,
if,
if facebook built this thing tomorrow
and announced it or rumor spread that
they had built it,
right.
What are the implications for Russia and
China?
Well,
in so far as they are as adversarial as
they are now,
it would be rational for them to just
new California,
right?
Because,
because the happiness device is,
there's a winner take all scenario.
I mean you,
you,
when the world,
if you have this device,
you can turn the lights off in China.
You know,
the moment you have this device,
you can just,
it's the ultimate.
Um,
cause literally you were talking about
and you know,
many people are made doubt whether such
a thing as possible.
But again,
we're just talking about the
implications of intelligence that can
make refinements to itself in over time.
Course that is bears no relationship to
what we experience as apes.
Right?
So you're talking about a system that
can make changes to his own source code,
um,
and become better and better at
learning.
And more and more knowledgeable has
instantaneous,
if we give it access to the Internet,
it has instantaneous access to all human
and machine knowledge.
And uh,
it does,
you know,
thousands of years of work every,
every day of our lives,
right?
They just thousands of years of
equivalent human level intellectual
work.
Um,
it's just a,
it's on,
I mean,
our intuitions completely falter at t
to,
to capture just how immensely powerful
such a thing would be.
And there's no reason to think this
isn't possible.
I mean,
the,
the most skeptical thing you can
honestly say about this is that this
isn't coming soon,
right?
It's like this is not,
but to say that this is not possible
makes no scientific sense at this point.
There's no reason to think that a
sufficiently advanced digital computer
can't pee,
can't instantiate general intelligence
of a sort that we have.
There's no reason to think that the
intelligence has to be at bottom some
form of information processing.
And if we get the algorithm right with
enough hardware resources and the,
and the limit is definitely not the
hardware at this point.
It's,
it's the,
the algorithms,
um,
there's just no reason to think this
could,
can't take off and,
and scale.
And then we would be in the presence of
something that is,
that is,
uh,
like having an,
an alternate human civilization in a box
that is making thousands of years of
progress every day.
Right?
So just imagine that if you had in a
box,
you know,
the 10 smartest people who've ever
lived,
and you know,
every time,
every week,
they make 20,000 years of progress,
right?
Because that is the actual,
we're talking about electronic circuits
being a million times faster than,
than biological circuits.
So even if it was just,
and I,
I believe I said this the last time we
talked about ai,
but this is,
you know,
this is what brings it home for me.
Even if it's just a matter of faster,
right?
It's not,
it's not anything especially spooky is
chest.
This can do human level,
intellectual work,
but just a million times faster.
And again,
this is totally under sells.
The prospects of superintelligence,
I think human level intellectual work
is,
is um,
uh,
it's going to seem pretty paltry in the
end.
But if you just imagine just speeding it
up,
if you imagine if a full,
if we were doing this podcast,
imagine how smart I would seem if
between every sentence.
I actually had a year to figure out what
I was going to say next.
Right?
And so I say this one sentence and you
say,
you asked me a question and then in my
world,
I just have a year,
I'm going to go spend the next year
getting,
getting ready for,
for Joe,
and it's going to be perfect.
And this is just compounding upon
itself.
Like not only can I not only,
uh,
I,
um,
am I working faster?
Ultimately I can change my,
my ability to work faster.
I mean,
like we were talking about software that
can change itself.
You're talking about something that that
becomes self improving.
So there's a compounding function there.
But,
um,
it's the point is,
is unimaginable,
uh,
in terms of how,
how much change this could effect.
And if you imagine the best case
scenario where this is under our
control,
right,
where there's no alignment problem,
where it's just,
it doesn't,
this thing doesn't do anything that
surprises us,
this thing we'll always take direction
from us.
It will never,
it will never develop interests of its
own.
Right.
Which is again the fear.
But let's,
let's just say this is totally obedient,
is just an oracle and a genie route,
you know,
in,
in one.
And um,
you know,
we say,
cure Alzheimer's and it cures
Alzheimer's.
You know,
you solve the protein folding problem
and,
and it just is,
it's just and running and to develop a
perfect nanotechnology and it does that.
This is all,
again,
going back to David Deutsch,
there's no reason to think this isn't
possible because anything that's
compatible with the laws of physics can
be done given the requisite knowledge,
right?
So you just,
you get enough intelligence,
as long as you're not violating the laws
of physics,
you can do something in that space.
Um,
so,
but the problem is this is a winner take
all scenario.
So facebook does it tomorrow and China
and Russia find out about it.
They can't afford to wait around to see
whether the US decides to do something
not entirely selfish with this,
right?
Because they're,
the,
their worst fears could be realized if
Donald Trump is president.
What's Donald Trump going to do with a
perfect ai when he has already told the
world that he hates Islam?
Right?
Um,
it's a,
um,
we would have to have a political and
economic system that allowed us to
absorb this ultimate wealth saved.
We'll wealth producing technology.
Um,
and,
and again,
so this may all sound like pure Psi Phi
craziness to people.
Um,
I don't think there is any reason to
believe that it is,
but walk way back from that edge of
craziness and just look at,
um,
dumb ai,
you know,
narrow ai,
just self driving cars and automation
and,
um,
intelligent algorithms that can do human
level work
that is already poised to change our
world massively and create massive
wealth inequality,
which we have.
We would have to figure out how to
spread this wealth.
You know,
what do you do when you can automate,
uh,
50% of,
of human labor?
Were you paying attention to the,
uh,
artificial intelligence go match?
Yeah.
Uh,
no,
I don't actually play goes,
so I wasn't paying that kind of
attention to it,
but I'm aware of what happened there and
you know,
the rules of go,
um,
not,
not so that I know,
actually I don't,
I don't,
I don't play it a,
no,
I don't,
I don't even know if I know vaguely how
you,
how you,
um,
how it looks when a game is played,
but I don't supposed to be very
complicated.
The more complicated and more
possibilities than chess.
Yeah.
And that's why it took 20 years longer
for a computer to be the best player in
the world.
Um,
it's,
it is.
Um,
did you see how the computer did it too?
Well,
I didn't,
I know,
I mean,
this is to the company that did it is,
um,
deep mind,
which was acquired by Google and they're
at the cutting edge of ai research and
yeah.
Well,
it's,
the cartoons are unfortunately not so
far from what is possible.
But,
um,
the,
uh,
yeah,
I mean there's,
again,
this is no,
this is not general intelligence.
Like we're talking about something like
these are not machines that can even
play tic Tac toe right now.
There's some,
there there've been some moves away from
this or like deep mind has trained an
algorithm to play all of the Atari Games
like,
oh,
from 1980 or whenever.
Um,
and it is very quickly became superhuman
on most of them.
I think.
I,
I don't think it's superhuman and all of
them yet,
but it could play in a space invaders
and all these and breakout and all these
games that are,
are,
um,
uh,
to highly unlike one another.
And it's the same algorithm becoming
expert in superhuman and all of them.
And that's,
that's a new paradigm and it's using a
technique called deep learning for that.
Um,
and that's,
and that's been very exciting and I will
be incredibly useful.
You know,
this is,
I mean,
the other,
the flip side of all of this,
I know that everything I tend to say on
this sound scary,
but this is all like,
I mean,
the next scariest thing is not to do any
of this stuff.
It's like we,
we want intelligence,
we want automation,
we want to figure out how to solve
problems that we can't get soft.
So like intelligence is the best thing
we've got.
So we want more of it.
Uh,
but we have to have a system where,
I mean,
it's scary that we have a system where
if you gave the best possible version of
it to one research lab or to one
government,
it's not obvious that that wouldn't
destroy humanity.
Right.
That wouldn't lead massive dislocations
where you'd have,
you know,
some trillionaire who's trumpeting his
new device and,
and just,
you know,
50% unemployment in the u s you know,
oh,
in a month.
Right?
I mean,
like,
he,
it's not obvious how we would absorb
this level of,
of progress.
Um,
and we,
we,
we definitely have to,
to figure out how to do it.
I know,
of course we can't assume the best case
scenario.
Right?
That's the best case scenario.
I think there's a few people that put it
the way you put it,
that terrify the shit out of people.
Right.
And everyone else seems to have this
rosy vision of increased longevity and
automated everything and everything
fixed and easy to get to work and
medical procedures would be easier.
Or they're going to know how to do it,
but everybody looks at it like,
we are always going to be here,
but are we obsolete?
I mean,
is this idea of a living thing that's
creative and wrapped up in emotions and
lust and desires and jealousy and all
the pettiness that we celebrated all the
time.
We still see it.
It's not getting any better.
Right.
If,
if we obsolete,
I mean,
what if this thing comes along and says,
listen,
there's a way to do it.
You're going to abandon all that stupid
shit and you can abandon all that makes
you all the stuff that makes you fun to
be around.
Yeah.
And also fucks with,
you could live three times as long
without that stuff.
Oh,
well,
I think it,
it would in the best case,
would usher in Ei.
Ei,
yeah.
The possibility of,
of kind of fundamentally creative life
where on the order of something like the
Matrix,
whether it's in the matrix or it's just
in the world that has been made as
beautiful as,
as possible,
um,
based on
what would functionally be an unlimited
resource of intelligence.
Let me just say,
it's just like for there to be a,
an ability to solve problems of a sword
that we can't currently imagine.
I mean,
it's just,
it really is like a place on the map
that you can't,
you can't,
and you can indicate it's over there.
You know,
it was like a blank spot on the map.
This is why it's called the singularity.
Right?
It's like,
this is it.
This is a,
uh,
it was,
it was John von Neumann,
the,
um,
the inventor of game theory who a
mathematician who,
um,
uh,
is one along with Alan Turing and a
couple of other people's was really
responsible for the computer revolution.
He was the first person to use this
term,
singularity,
uh,
to describe just this,
that,
that there's a speeding up of,
um,
information processing technology
and April a cultural reliance upon it,
uh,
beyond which we can't actually foresee
the level of change that can come over
our society.
It's like,
you know,
an event horizon pass,
which we can't.
Um,
and uh,
this certainly becomes true when you
talk about these intelligence systems
being able to make changes to
themselves.
And again,
we're talking mostly software is not,
I'm not imagining,
um,
I mean the,
the most important breakthroughs
certainly at the level of,
of better software.
I mean the,
is we have,
in terms of the computing power that if
the physical hardware on earth,
it's not,
that's not what's limiting our ai at the
moment.
It's not like we need more,
more,
uh,
hardware.
Um,
but we will get more hardware to up to
the limits of physics and it'll,
it get smaller and smaller as it has a,
and you know,
if quantum computing becomes possible,
um,
or practical,
that will,
uh,
actually David Deutsch is,
is,
um,
the physicist I mentioned is one of the
fathers of the concept of quantum
computing.
Um,
that will open up a whole nother area,
you know,
extreme of computing power.
That is,
I'm not at all analogous to the kinds
of,
uh,
machines we have now.
But,
um,
it's just when you imagine
people don't,
people seem to always want to,
I just had this conversation with Neil
degrasse Tyson on my podcast.
He named dropper.
Yeah.
I know.
It was just,
I'm just keeping pookie people.
I'm just,
I'm just attributing these ideas to him.
Uh,
he's not a,
he doesn't take this line at all.
He's not at all,
he thinks it's all bullshit.
Right.
He's not at all worried about Ai.
What does he think?
He thinks that,
you know,
we just,
we just use,
he's drawing an analogy from how we,
you currently use computers that they
just,
they just keep helping us do what we
want to do.
Like we decide what we want to do with
computers and we just add them to our
process and that process becomes
automated and then we'll find new jobs
somewhere else.
Like you didn't,
you don't need a stenographer once you
have voice recognition technology and
um,
uh,
that's not a problem.
A stenographer we'll find something else
to do.
And so the economic dislocations isn't
that bad and um,
computers will just get better than they
are and you know,
eventually Siri will actually work,
you know,
and you'll,
she'll answer your questions.
Well and you're not,
it's not going to be a laugh line what
Siri said to you today.
And,
um,
then all of this,
we'll just proceed to make life better
right now.
Um,
none of that is imagining what it will
be like to make it,
because it would be a certain point
where you'll have systems that are,
you know,
it's like
the Cha,
the best chess player on earth is now
always going to be a computer,
right?
It's never,
there's no,
there's not going to be a human born
tomorrow that's going to be better than
the best computer.
I mean,
it's like,
it's already like we have superhuman
chess players on earth.
Now imagine having computers that are
superhuman at every,
uh,
every task that is relevant,
every intellectual task,
right?
So the best physicist is a computer.
You know,
the best medical diagnostician is a
computer.
The best,
um,
prover of math theorems has a computer.
The best engineer is a computer,
right?
Then there's no,
there's no reason why we're not headed
there.
I mean,
it would be the only reason I could see
we're not headed there is it's something
massively dislocating happens that
prevents us from continuing to improve
our intelligent machines.
But if you just,
the moment you admit that intelligence
is just a matter of information
processing and you admit that we will
continue to improve our machines unless
something heinous happens because this
is intelligence and automation are the
most valuable things we have.
Um,
at a certain point,
whether you think it's in five years or
500 years,
we're going to find ourselves in the
presence of super intelligent machines.
And then at that point,
the best source of innovation for the
next generation of software or hardware
or both will be the machines themselves.
Right?
So then,
so then you just have,
then that's where you get what,
what was,
what the mathematician Ij good described
as as the intelligence explosion,
which is just the process can take off
on its own.
Um,
and this is where the singularity
people,
um,
either either are hopeful or worried.
Um,
but you know,
cause there's nothing,
there's no guarantee that this process
will be,
remain aligned with our interests.
And,
and every person who I meet,
even,
you know,
very smart people like Neil,
um,
who says they're not worried about this.
When you actually drill down on why
they're not worried,
you find that they're actually not
imagining machines making changes to
their own source code.
Um,
and they're not an or they're,
they,
they simply believe that this is so far
away that we don't have to worry about
it now.
Right.
And that's actually a non sequitur.
I mean,
to say that this is far away is not
actually grappling with,
it's not an argument this isn't going to
happen.
And,
um,
and it's based on what to,
and it's,
and it's based on,
first of all,
there's no,
there's no reason to believe Jamie want
to find out where it is.
Um,
there's no,
I mean we don't know how long it will
take us to prepare for this.
Right?
So like,
like if,
if you were,
if you knew this,
it was going to take 50 years for this
to happen,
right.
Is 50 years enough for us to prepare
politically and economically to deal
with the ramifications of this and,
and to do it and to add to say nothing
of actually building the ai safely in a
way that's aligned with our interests.
I don't know.
I mean 50 so 50 years is,
it's like we've had the iphone for what,
10 years?
Nine years?
I'm it,
it's like 50 years,
not a lot of time,
right.
To,
to deal,
to deal with this.
And um,
this has no reason to think it's,
it's that far away.
If we keep making progress,
I mean it's,
it's not,
it will be amazing if it were 500 years
away.
I mean,
that,
that seems like it's,
it's,
it's more likely from what I am in the
sense I get from the people who are
doing this work,
it's far more likely to be 50 years than
500 years.
Like,
you know,
um,
uh,
I mean the p at the people who think
this is a long,
long way off or,
I mean they're saying,
you know,
50 to 100 years,
no one says 500 years.
No,
no.
As far as I know,
no one who was actually close to this
work and some people think it could be
in five years.
Right.
I mean the people who are,
you know,
like the deep mind people who are very
close to this or are the sorts of people
who say,
cause the people,
the people who are close to his work are
astonished by what's happened in the
last 10 years.
We went from a place of,
you know,
very little progress too,
wow,
this is all of a sudden really,
really interesting and powerful.
And um,
and again,
progress is compounding in a way that's
counter intuitive.
People systematically overestimate how
much change can happen in a year and
underestimate how much change can happen
in 10 years.
And I,
you know,
as far as estimating how much change can
happen in 50 or a hundred years,
I don't know that anyone is good at
that.
How could you be with giant leaps come
giant exponential leaps off those leaps.
And it's,
it's almost impossible for us to really
predict what we're going to be looking
at 50 years from now.
But I don't,
I don't know what they're going to think
about us.
That's what's most bizarre about it as
well.
We really might be obsolete if we look
at how ridiculous we are.
Look at this political campaign,
look at what we pay attention to in the
news.
Look at the things we really focus on
where our strange,
ridiculous animal and w y if we look
back on,
you know,
some strange dinosaur that at a weird
neck,
why should that fucking thing make it,
you know,
why should we make it?
We,
we might be here to make that thing.
And that thing takes over from here with
no emotions,
no lust,
no greed,
and just purely existing electronically
and for what reason?
Well,
that,
that's a little scary there.
There are computer scientists who when
you talk about why they're not worried
or talk to them about why they're not
worried,
they just swallow this pill without any
qualm that we're going to make.
The thing that is far more powerful and
beautiful and important than we are.
And it doesn't matter what happens to
us.
I mean,
that was our role.
Our role was to build these mechanical
gods and,
and it's fine if they squash us.
Um,
and I've literally heard a,
a,
people say,
I've heard someone give a talk.
I mean,
that's what woke me up to,
oh,
how interesting in this area is.
I went to this conference in San Juan
about a year ago.
Um,
and there were,
uh,
you know,
like the people from deep mind were
there and there were the people who were
very close to this work were there.
And,
um,
I mean to hear some of the reasons why
you shouldn't be worried from people who
were interested in,
in calming the fear is so they could get
on with doing their very important work.
Um,
it was amazing because they were highly
uncompelling reasons not to be worried.
It's just,
um,
so,
so they had a,
they had a desire to be compelled.
They're not,
they're not well,
not well known that people,
people want to do this.
There's a deep assumption in many of
these people that we can figure it out
as we go along.
Right?
It's like,
you know,
it's just like,
we're going to,
we're just going to get,
going to get closer.
We're foot.
We're far enough away now.
Even five year,
even if it's five years,
five years,
we'll,
we'll get there.
Once we get closer,
once we get something a little scary,
then we'll pull the brakes and talk
about it.
But the problem is they are a sent,
everyone is essentially in a race
condition by default.
And you have,
you know,
Google is racing against facebook and
the u s is racing against China and
every,
every group is racing against every
other group.
Um,
however you want to conceive of groups.
This,
this is a,
to be the first one to be the first one
with
incredibly powerful,
narrow ai is to be the next,
you know,
multibillion dollar company,
right?
So everyone's trying to get there and
uh,
if they suddenly get there and sort of
overshoot a little bit and now they've
got something like,
you know,
general intelligence or something close,
um,
what we're relying on every,
and they know everyone else's attempting
to do this,
right?
Um,
W we don't have a system set up where
everyone can pull the breaks together
and say,
listen,
we've got to stop racing here.
We have to share everything.
We have to share the wealth,
we have to share the information,
we have to um,
this truly has to be open source in
every conceivable way.
And um,
we have to diffuse this winner take all
dynamic.
Um,
you know,
I think we need something like a
Manhattan project to figure out how to
do that.
You know,
not if not to figure out how to build
the AI,
but to figure out how to build it in a
way that does not create an arms race
that does not create,
um,
an incentive to build unsafe ai,
which is almost certainly going to be
easier than building safe ai and just to
work out all of these issues because
it's,
it's not because what I think we are,
we're going to build this by default.
We're just going to keep building more
and more intelligent machines and this
is going to be done in by everyone who
can,
can do it with each generation.
If we were even talking about
generations,
it's going to be,
it will have the tools made by the prior
generation that are more powerful than
anyone imagined a hundred years ago.
And it just,
it gets going to keep going like that.
Did anybody actually make that quote
about giving birth to the mechanical
gods?
I,
no,
that was just made.
Yeah,
but it was,
there was a scientist that actually was
thinking and saying that,
but that was,
that was the content of what he was
saying.
He's like,
what are we going to build the next
species that is far more important than
we are?
And that's a good thing.
And it,
well,
and actually I can go there with him.
I mean,
it actually,
the only,
the only
caveat here is that unless they're not
conscious,
right?
Like if you,
the true horror for me is that we can
build things more intelligent than we
are,
more powerful than we are.
Uh,
and that can squash us and they might
not,
they might be unconscious,
right?
There might be nothing like the universe
could go dark if they squash us,
right?
Or,
or at least our corner of the universe
could go dark.
Um,
and yet these things will be immensely
powerful.
Um,
so if,
and this is just,
you know,
the jury's out on this,
but if there's nothing about
intelligence scaling that demands that
consciousness come along for the ride,
um,
then it's possible that,
I mean,
nobody thinks our machines are,
you know,
very few people would think are machines
that are intelligent or conscious.
Right?
So at what point does consciousness come
online?
Um,
maybe it's possible to build super
intelligence that's unconscious,
you know,
super powerful,
does everything better than we do.
You know,
it'll recognize your emotion better
than,
than another person can,
but then the lights aren't on that.
That's,
that's also I think possible.
But maybe it's not possible,
but that's,
that's the worst case scenario because
in the ethical silver lining and
speaking,
you know,
outside of our self interest now,
but just from a bird's eye view,
um,
the ethical silver lining to building
these mechanical gods that are conscious
is that,
yes,
okay.
We've,
in fact if we have built something that
is far wiser and has far more beautiful
experiences and deeper experiences of
the universe and we could ever imagine
and there there's something that it's
like to be that thing that's just,
you know,
it is a,
has a kind of a God like uh,
experience.
Um,
well that would be a very good thing
then we will have built you,
we will have built something that was,
you know,
if you stand outside of our narrow self
interest,
I can understand why he would say that
he,
he was just assuming what was scary
about that particular talk cause he was
assuming that consciousness comes along
for the ride here.
And I don't know that that is a safe
assumption.
Well and the really terrifying thing is
who,
if,
if this is constantly improving itself
and it's under the Beck and call of a
person then so it's either conscious or
unconscious where it acts as itself,
right?
It acts as an individual thinking unit.
Right?
Or as a a a thing outside of it's aware,
right?
Either it is or it isn't.
And if it isn't aware and some person
can manipulate it,
like imagine if it's getting 10,000,
how many,
how many thousands of years in a week
did you say?
I'll go,
well,
if it was just improvement,
it was just a million times faster than
we are.
It's 20,000 years,
20,000 years in a week and a weekend in
a week.
So with every week,
this thing constantly gets better at
even doing that.
Right?
So it's reprogramming itself.
So it's all exponential.
Presumably it just,
it just imagine again that you could
keep it in the most restricted case.
You could just keep it at our level,
but
just,
just faster,
just a million times faster.
But if it did,
all of these things,
if it kept going and kept every week was
thousands of years,
right?
We're going to control it.
A person.
No,
think that's even more insane.
Imagine being in dialogue with something
that had that,
that lived the 20,000 years of human
progress in a week.
And you come back,
you know,
on Monday and say,
listen,
um,
I,
that thing I told you to do last Monday,
I want to change that up and this thing
has made 20,000 years of progress.
Um,
and if it's in a condition where it has
access,
I mean,
so we're imagining this thing,
you know,
in a box,
air gapped from the Internet and it's
got nothing.
He's got no way to get out.
Right.
Uh,
even that is an unstable situation.
But just imagine this emerging in some
way online,
right?
Already being out in the wild.
Right?
So let's say it's in a financial market,
right?
Um,
that's again,
this is what worries me most about this
and what is also interesting is that our
intuitions here,
I think the primary intuition that
people have is no,
no,
that's just,
that's just not possible.
Or not at all likely.
But if,
if you're going to fund,
if you,
you're going to think it's impossible or
even unlikely,
you have to find something wrong with
the claim.
That intelligence is just a matter of
information processing.
Um,
I don't know any scientific reason to
doubt that claim at the moment.
Um,
and uh,
very good reasons to believe that it's
just undoubtable,
uh,
and the,
and you have to doubt that we will
continue to make progress in the design
of intelligent machines.
And,
but once you then is then that all this
left is just time,
right?
If,
if,
if intelligence is just information
processing and we were going to continue
to build better and better information
processors,
at a certain point we're going to build
something that is superhuman.
Um,
and so whether it's in five years or 50,
it's,
it's a huge,
I mean it's,
it's the biggest change in human history
I think we can imagine.
Right?
Um,
so,
uh,
and then people,
I what I felt fine.
I keep finding myself in the presence of
people who seem at least to my eye to be
refusing to imagine it like late,
they're treating it like the y two k
virus or whatever where it's just the y
two k bug where it just may or may not
be an issue.
Right?
Like it,
like it's a hypothetical,
like May this is just,
we're going to get there and it's,
it's just going to be,
it's either not going to happen or it's,
it's,
it's going to be trivial.
But how you don't,
if you don't have an argument for why
this isn't going to happen,
uh,
then you have to have then,
then you're left with,
okay,
what's it gonna be like to have,
uh,
systems that are better than we are at
everything in the intellectual space.
Um,
and
you know,
what will happen if that suddenly
happens in one country and not in
another,
right?
It's,
um,
it's,
uh,
I mean,
it has enormous implications,
but it just sounds like science fiction.
Yup.
I don't know what's scarier.
The idea that an artificial intelligence
can emerge.
It's conscious,
it's aware of itself and that acts to
present per,
per protect itself or the idea that a
person,
a regular person like of today could be
in control of essentially a god.
Right?
Because if this thing continues to get
smarter and smarter with every week and
more and more power and more and more
potential,
more and more understanding,
thousands of years,
I mean it's just,
yeah,
this one person,
uh,
per regular person controlling that is
almost more terrifying than creating a
new life or,
or any group of people who don't have
the total welfare of humanity as their
central concern.
And so just imagine,
I mean,
what would,
what would China do with it now?
Right?
What would we,
what would we do if we thought China,
you know,
Baidu or whatever,
or some Chinese company was on the verge
of this thing.
Um,
what would it be rational for us to do?
You know?
I mean,
if North Korea had it,
it would be,
it'd be rational to nuke them given what
they say about,
you know,
their relationship with the rest of the
world.
So it's,
um,
well that kind of power.
Would you say rational that of power is,
it's so life changing.
It's so what paradigm shifting,
right?
But if you to,
to wind this back to what someone like
Neil degrasse Tyson would say,
is that the only basis for fear is,
yeah,
don't give your superintelligent ai to
the next Hitler,
right?
That's,
that's obviously bad.
But if we don't,
if we're not idiots and we just use it,
well,
we're fine.
And that I think is an intuition that is
just,
that's just a failure to,
to unpack what is entailed by,
again,
something like an intelligence
explosion,
a process that once,
once you're talking about something that
is able to change itself and you have to
get it.
So what would it be like to guarantee
level?
Let's say we decide,
okay,
we're just not going to build anything
that can make changes to his own source
code.
You know,
any change to it,
to software at a certain point is going
to have to be run through a human brain.
Um,
and we're going to have veto power.
Well,
is every person working on ai going to
abide by that rule?
It's like we,
we've agreed not to clone humans,
right?
But you know,
we're going to stand by that agreement
for the,
in the rest of human history.
And is,
is a,
is our agreement binding on China or
Singapore or you know,
any other country that might think
otherwise.
It's just we have a,
it's a free for all and at a certain
point we're going to be,
you know,
close enough.
Everyone's going to be close enough to
making the final breakthrough that,
um,
unless we have some,
uh,
agreement about how to proceed if
someone is going to get there first,
that is a terrifying scenario of the
future.
You know,
you cemented this last time you were
here,
but not as extreme as this time.
You seem to be accelerating the
rhetoric.
Exactly.
Yes.
You're going deep.
Yeah.
Boy,
I hope you're wrong.
I'm on team Neil degrasse Tyson,
right?
This one,
Neil.
Um,
and also in defensive of the other side
too,
I should say that,
you know,
like,
so David Deutsch also thinks I'm wrong,
but he thinks I'm wrong because we will
integrate ourselves with these machines.
I mean,
so that we,
this will be,
there'll be extensions of ourselves and
they can't help but be aligned with us
because we will,
we will be connected to them.
That seems to be the only way we could
all get along.
We have to merge become one.
But I just think there's no,
there's no deep reason why,
even if we decided to do that,
right?
Like in the u s or,
or,
or in half the world,
um,
one,
there's,
I think there are reasons to worry that
even that could go haywire,
but there's no guarantee that someone
else couldn't just build ai in a box.
I mean,
if we,
if we can build ai such that we can
merge our brains with it,
um,
someone can also just build ai in a box.
Right.
And,
and that's,
uh,
um,
and then then inherit all the other
problems that people are saying.
We don't have to worry about.
If it was a good coen brothers movie,
it would be invented in the middle of
the presidency of Donald Trump.
And so then that's when ai would go
live.
And then ai would have to challenge
Donald Trump and they would have like an
insult context,
but that that's when this thing becomes
so comically,
uh,
terrifying where it's just,
just imagine Donald Trump being in a
position to make the final decisions on
topics like this for the country.
That is,
acne is going to do this almost
certainly in the near term.
It's like he should,
we have a Manhattan project on this
point,
Mr President.
Um,
you know,
the idea that anything of a value could
be happening between his ears on this
topic.
We're a hundred others.
Like it I think is now really
inconceivable.
And so what w what,
what price could we,
might we pay for that kind of
inattention and,
and you know,
self satisfied in attention to these
kinds of issues?
Well,
this,
this issue,
if this is real and if this could go
live in 50 years,
this is the issue.
Yeah.
Unless we fuck ourselves up beyond
repair before then and shut the power
off if it keeps going.
Yeah.
No,
I think it is.
I think it is the issue,
but unfortunately it's the,
it's the issue that doesn't,
it sounds like a goof.
Yeah,
it does just sound,
you sound like a crack pot even worrying
about this issue.
It sounds completely ridiculous,
but that might be what's how it's
sneaking in.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
it,
just imagine that the tiny increment
that would make suddenly make it
compelling.
I mean,
just imagine,
I mean chest doesn't do it because chess
is so far from any central human
concern.
But just imagine if your,
if your phone recognized your emotional
state better than any than your best
friend or your wife or anyone in your
life.
And it did it reliably.
Right.
So as your body liked that movie with
Joaquin Phoenix,
her,
he falls in love with his phone.
Right?
I mean,
that's just not,
you know,
that is not far off that far off as not,
it's a very discreet ability.
I mean,
you could do that.
You could do that without any,
any other ability in the phone.
Really.
It's like,
it doesn't,
it doesn't have to to,
uh,
stand on the shoulders of any other kind
of intelligence.
It could just,
you know,
he just,
you have,
I mean,
this could be,
you could do this with just brute force
in the same way that you have a great
chess player that doesn't necessarily
understand that is playing chess.
You could have it,
you know,
it's kind of facial recognition,
facial recognition of emotion and the,
and the tone of voice,
recognition of emotion and um,
the idea that it's going to,
it's going to be a very long time for
computers that get better than people at
that I think is very farfetched.
I was thinking,
yeah,
think you're right.
I was
just thinking how strange would it be if
you had like headphones on and your
phone was in your pocket and you have
rational conversations with your phone?
Like your phone knew you better than you
know,
you like,
I mean,
I don't know what to do.
I don't think I was out of line.
She yelled at me.
I mean,
what should I say?
And it would have listened to every one
of your conversations with your friends.
Exactly.
Train up on that and just talk to you
about it and go,
listen man,
this is what you got gotta do.
I was talking to political,
you were sounding angry.
You got defensive,
you got defensive.
Why were you so to hold that Joe?
Yeah.
Apologize,
relax.
Let's all move on.
If you could accelerate it or,
okay.
You right man.
Right man,
and like you're talking to this little
artificial.
Maybe that's the first version of
artificial intelligence that we suggest.
We'd say,
all right,
let's give it a shot and like self help
guys in your phone,
you have like a personal trainer in your
phone.
How to talk to girls at first.
Breakthrough yet slow down,
dude.
Slow down.
You're talking too fast.
Got To cool.
Yeah,
I mean literally like giving you
information.
That would be like step one.
That'd be like the Sony Walkman.
Remember when you had a Walkman,
like a cassette player that was like,
that was like a vcr when we were on our
way to what we have today where you have
fucking 30,000 songs in your phone or
something.
I think I remember the first Walkman.
The first thing I just want to it back
when I skied,
there was something called,
it was called astral tunes or something.
It was like,
it was like a car radio that,
that you could just put on in a pack on
your chest.
Um,
yeah,
it was,
they kept coming out with those sounds.
They would get smaller and smaller.
So then that little,
the little dude would start telling you,
Yo man,
dude,
listen to keep it.
Place me over a year.
Just let him stick me in.
Your brain will be together all the
time.
Yeah,
yeah.
Giving you good advice for years,
Bro.
Let me and your brain.
And so you and this little artificial
intelligence,
do you have a relationship over time?
And eventually it talks you into getting
your head drilled and the screw it in
there and your artificial intelligence
is always powered by your central
nervous system.
Did you,
have you seen most of these movies?
Like did you see her and,
and no,
I didn't.
Okay.
No.
Did you see Alex?
Mark and I,
that was one of my,
that was good.
Top 10 all time favorite movies.
Yeah,
I loved that movie actually.
I like it.
I saw it twice.
I said,
I,
I was slow to realize how well,
uh,
they,
they did it.
I mean,
it was just the first time I saw it,
I thought,
um,
I wasn't as impressed and I watched it
again and they really,
I mean,
first of all,
the performance of,
of um,
I forgot the actress's name.
Uh,
the candor,
at least you have a candor today.
Um,
there was a woman who plays the robot in
an x,
Monica.
It was just fantastic.
But,
um,
scary.
Good tuck you in.
Anything.
We're getting a little full on time.
Yeah.
What do we like five hours in a half
hours in.
But I just got to know how to spot to
fill up.
Wait a minute.
How many hours?
Four and a half hour.
No computers about to fill up.
Yeah we did.
We just did a four and a half hour
pocket.
We ready to keep going to Jesus.
Jamie didn't cock block.
You know what man,
once you opened up that box up Pandora's
box of artificial,
I haven't heard you guys discussed
it and I've looked up,
is there any sort of concept of autism
in ai?
Like a spectrum of ai?
Like oh,
there are dumb ai and there's going to
be smart Ai.
I know.
So,
I mean the scary thing so that yeah,
it's like super autism.
There's no,
um,
across the board there's,
I think that super intelligence and
motivation and goals are totally
separable.
So you could have a super intelligent
machine that is purposed toward a goal
that just seems completely absurd and
harmful and non common sensical.
And they said they,
the example that that Nick Bostrom uses
in his,
in his book superintelligence which was
a great book,
um,
and did more to inform my thinking on
this topic than any other source.
Um,
he talks about it a paperclip maximizer.
You could,
you could build a super intelligent
paperclip maximizer.
Now,
not that anyone would do this,
but the point is you could build a
machine that was,
that was smarter than we are in every
conceivable way,
but all it wants to do is produce paper
clips.
Right.
Now that seems counterintuitive,
but there's no,
there's no reason when you kind of dig
deeply into this,
there's no reason why you couldn't build
a superhuman paperclip maximizer.
I just wants to turn everything,
you know,
just literally the atoms in your body
would be better used as paperclips.
Um,
and so this is just the point he's
making is that superintelligence could
be very counterintuitive.
It's not necessarily going to inherit
everything we find as,
you know,
common sensical or,
or emotionally appropriate or wise or
desirable.
Uh,
it could be totally foreign,
totally trivial in some way,
you know,
focused on something that means nothing
to us,
but means everything to it because of
some quirk and how it's motivation
system is structured and yet it can
build the perfect nanotechnology that
will allow it to build more paperclips.
Right?
So,
um,
and Lisa,
at least,
I don't think anyone can see why that's
ruled out in advance.
I mean,
there's no reason why we would
intentionally build that,
but the fear is we might build something
that either is not
perfectly aligned with our goals and our
common sense and our,
and our,
um,
aspirations and that it could form some
kind of separate in instrumental goals
to get what his wants,
wants that are totally incompatible with
life as we know it.
And that's,
you know,
I mean,
again,
the,
the examples of this are always
cartoonish.
Like,
you know how I mean,
Elon Musk said,
you know,
if you built up super intelligent
machine and he told it to reduce spam,
well then it could just kill all people
as a great way to reduce spam.
Right.
Um,
but see the reason why that's La,
that's laughable,
but there's,
you can't assume the common sense won't
be there unless we've built it.
Right?
Like,
you have to have anticipated all of
this.
You can't,
if you say,
take me to the airport as fast as you
can.
Again,
this is Bostrom,
you know,
and you have a super intelligent,
automatic a car.
Um,
you know,
a self driving car,
you'll just,
you'll get to the airport covered in
vomit because he'll just,
it's,
it's just going to go as fast as it can
go.
Um,
so it's a,
it's our intuitions about what it would
mean to be super intelligent
necessarily,
or are,
um,
I mean there's no,
we have to correct for them,
cause I think our intuitions are,
are bad.
[inaudible].